as we continue into our journey of
chemistry we're going to gain more and
more appreciation for the periodic table
of elements we're going to realize that
it gives us all sorts of insights about
how different elements relate to each
other and we're going to talk about one
of those insights and that's Atomic radi
Trends so we're going to talk about by
looking at the periodic table of
elements can we deduce how the different
sizes of these atoms might relate to
each other so let's just start with the
group one elements right over here so
we're in this First Column what do you
think is going to happen to the radius
of these atoms as we go down this First
Column as we go from hydrogen to lithium
sodium potassium so on and so
forth well you might be thinking well as
we go down this we're adding a lot more
electrons the outermost electrons even
though we have the same number of veence
electrons we have one veence electron
for everything in group one that one
veence electron is at a higher and
higher energy level it is at a further
and further out energy shell and so one
way to think about it is if you have the
nucleus of an atom here and you have
that one veence electron out here well
the more that you go down this group
you're going to have more electrons in
between in between this is a pretty
messy drawing in between that nucleus
and that veence electron and that veence
electron is going to be further and
further are out because it's at a higher
energy level so because of that one you
have shielding from these inner
electrons from that positive nucleus and
this is at a higher and higher energy
level as you go down this group the
radius increases so let me write that
down increases what are we talking about
we're talking about Atomic radi
increases so for example cium or Fran
well let's go with francium francium is
a much larger atom than hydrogen now
what happens if we were to go
horizontally what happens if we were to
go across a period here so let's let me
do this in different color what if we
were to go if we were look at say period
four and if we were to go from potassium
to the right all the way to Krypton what
do you think is going to happen here
think about it for a second before I
explain it to you all right so this is a
situation where we're going to keep
adding electrons as we move to the right
but you're not going to be adding
electrons to higher and higher energy
levels you're either going to be
backfilling in the transition elements
or you're going to be adding electrons
to your veence shell so you're not
having higher and higher energy
electrons so they're not going to be any
further away from that nucleus but as
you go from left to right across one of
these periods you're adding protons so
you're making the center of that atom
more and more more positively charged so
it's going to pull in those outer shell
electrons more and more and more so
based on that you would expect to see
that the radius
decreases as you go from left to right
along the periodic table of elements and
we can confirm this intuition by looking
at this plot here so what this is doing
is it's plotting every element in the
periodic table of elements based on its
atomic number and its atomic radius
so for example this right over here is
hydrogen and then your atomic number
increases you're at Helium and our
intuition is correct it looks like the
radius has decreased and then we go into
the second period and actually let me
just show each
period here so if we go into period two
here lithium has the largest radius and
as we go from left to right in Period
two we get to smaller and smaller radi
now if we go to period three we see the
same Trend again so we see confirmed in
the actual data that Trend that as you
go from left to right on a period the
radi or the radius decreases now let's
think about a group which is where we
started well across or up down any group
if we go to group one right over here we
see that intuition you go from hydrogen
to lithium to sodium to Krypton all the
way to cesium here we have our radius is
increasing as we're adding higher and
higher energy shells you see the same
thing with group two this is the second
column in the periodic table of elements
so the data confirms our intuition